it's come to this no more civil
discourse what's happening in this
country today is beyond anything we've
ever seen in American politics political
debate at the very heart of the founding
of this country has devolved into
political harassment and outright
political abuse Sarah Huckabee Sanders
the White House press secretary one of
the most prestigious jobs in Washington
DC out to dinner places her order and is
then told to leave by the owner because
she works for the President of the
United States
Sarah quietly leaves Department of
Homeland Security Secretary Kirsten
Nielsen this week was literally screamed
and heckled out of a restaurant while
eating her dinner Trump supporters are
being harassed all across this country
by an hysterical left unwilling to
accept the decision and the will of the
American people who put Donald Trump in
office these unhinged leftists are
normalizing outrageous behavior which is
only getting worse so why is this
happening
once the Democrats 24/7 Russia collusion
illusion nonsense fizzled because there
was no evidence of wrongdoing or
collusion other than corruption on the
part of those at the top level of the
FBI and DOJ to frame Donald Trump the
left needed a new issue a new deflection
to some other made up wrongdoing on the
part of Donald Trump what to accuse him
of what can we blame him for now they
then deflect to the inhumane separation
of children from their families at the
border now I want to be clear I have
spent my professional life fighting for
children children who've been victimized
and injured and harmed there is nothing
more heartbreaking than
children being separated from their
parents everyday family courts separate
parents from their children everyday
criminal judges separate parents from
their children and everyday children are
placed in foster care away from their
parents and I haven't heard anyone on
the Left complain now for those of you
who are so blinded by Trump hatred there
are laws in this country a Primmer
when you cross the border into these
United States illegally expect to be
arrested you do not have the right to
come here we did not invite you here and
you cannot stay here but on your way out
you can thank Bill Clinton and his
Flores settlement that requires that
children be taken away from their
parents within 20 days of crossing the
border and you can also thank Presidents
Bush and Obama for signing into law the
children cannot be detained at the
border longer than 20 days under the
trafficking Victims Protection acts and
now everyone wants to go after President
Trump this is not something that
President Trump created George Bush did
nothing about it
Barack Obama did nothing about it and by
the way Laura Bush we haven't seen you
in for a while thanks for entering the
fray and calling the removal of children
cruel and inhumane why didn't you just
roll over one night and tell your
husband the president that his zero
tolerance policy was cruel and inhumane
the left just doesn't care what the
facts are politicians are willing to
stand up and totally contradict
themselves in their effort to create
political chaos hatred and abuse and
Steny Hoyer the most senior ranking
Democrat in Congress says this he is
taking infant children hostage wrenching
them from the arms of their parents
Kromah ties in them perhaps for life hey
stenny you've been in Congress for 37
years
you said nothing during the clinton bush
or Obama administration and now you're
worried and Senator Kamala Harris says
this we imprisoned them Kamala when you
were Attorney General in California over
1 million people were separated from
their children the separating of
children from families only hurt if
Donald Trump is President and Peter
Fonda he says we should rip the
president's son from his mother's arm
and put him in a cage with pedophiles
hey Peter how about you get on your
motorcycle and take an easy ride off the
planet
JLo but Mosin trashes a president for
this separation of children from parents
except this child is separated from her
parents in Mosel by Isis even Time
magazine is so blinded that they ignore
all journalistic standards to trash
Donald Trump the child depicted here on
the cover was not separated from her
mother
in fact the child here was taken by the
mother without the father's permission
or knowledge or consent from her home
country and this mother by the way had
previously been deported we cannot allow
our country to be overrun by illegal
immigrants the only resolution to this
problem is to build a wall amnesty does
nothing but create an incentive for
additional crossings by illegals make no
mistake the Democrats are simply looking
for an issue for the 2018 midterms and
even if they have to lie create false
images and a movement to intimidate
Trump supporters they will stop at
nothing
folks were in a very dangerous place
right now hate is hate hate leads to
harassment and abuse and that abuse
leads to violence and that violence
leads to retaliation any threat of
violence that conjures up a visual of
violence is more dangerous than just
having different political views we are
a very short distance from those who are
willing to cross the line of political
debate to those willing to cross the
line into political abuse